a bill my name is Victor and I'm from
Markham Ontario the question I have for
you this Tuesday pertains to human
evolution and space colonization I
understand that humans are constantly
evolving to adapt to the environment
around us
for instance astronauts who have gone on
long expeditions need to be carried out
their spacecraft after returning back to
earth so what kind of evolutions do you
think we might see in humans if we
colonize a planet with lower gravity
like Mars Thank You Victor Victor Victor
this is an excellent question and
appreciate you asking it notice that it
is my strong belief that we will not
colonize Mars it's a very romantic
notion you live in Ontario I don't know
no but it looks like your ancestors came
from the west the left coast of Canada
and a lot of people who first colonized
Canada from work from Europe and we have
this vision that you leave your native
country because you're getting
religiously persecuted or someone's
invested is making you a good deal on
going to a new world where you can start
a new life and the people that came to
North America from Europe thought this
was great they're going across North
America eating everything foraging in
the forest cutting down trees making
farms finding all these remarkable
natural resources especially in Canada
all these wonderful Mineral Resources
and they had a fabulous life but
everywhere they went
there was water and most especially they
could breathe that is huge and I say to
everybody who thinks that they or
everybody he or she who thinks he or she
wants to colonize Mars go colonize
Antarctica see what you think and don't
no no no not us going to the seashore
where the Penguins are swimming and the
Orca are eating the seals and there's
krill for the very large whales now go
to the Dry Valleys
where at
every gets barely gets close to the
freezing point of water when there is
water as in snow - rained in the century
there's nothing to eat and see what you
think really see if that appeals to you
yes
humankind has a base in Antarctica
populated by hundreds of people some
many of them are scientists and they've
made important discoveries about
planetary science about the earth and
our environment and climates and so on
but Mars is a really just inhospitable
place with that said there's a movie
coming out called the worlds between us
where a kid is born on Mars apparently
surreptitiously a pregnant woman ends up
on Mars against all protocols or
whatever science fiction things they had
to put in there to get her there and the
kid goes up on Mars and he ends up
eventually he comes to the earth and his
heart isn't strong enough for him to
carry on he can't jump and of course he
falls in love with an earth girl and
there's some issues that you always have
when Earth ancestor boy come from Mars
to earth there's some problems as he
can't run or whatever it's like boy in
the bubble so it might be a cool movie
I've only seen a portion of it but it's
called worlds between us which addresses
your question I think from a
science-fiction standpoint then when you
say how will humans evolved humans are
evolving but boy it's it's hardly
noticeable you know humans are all over
the earth now and I say all the time
they run this test continually Vicktor
humans from different parts of the world
have sex with each other and produce
more humans but you still end up with a
human so I'm not sure humans would
evolve much on Mars unless there really
was selection pressure only women that
could handle the Martian gravity only
the offspring that could handle the
Martian gravity would do well
only the humans offspring that could
handle ultraviolet light perhaps or
could hander handle bitter cold even
when you have a spacesuit there might be
cold extremities your fingers and
but that selection pressure would be
really slow and I just save it all the
time a science base on Mars yes let's go
a human colony where your families are
going to retire and or raise kids and
build playgrounds as it that's a lot
harder thing but you're asking a great
great question Victor look at the movie
and see what you think carry on